bob's in the pubs in the discord
why is bob in the discord he's like i
think he's only two players though maybe
uh don't don't look at it bob don't look
at it
he's gone
oh bomb
i think i took over as player one i
don't want to be player one how did you
take over my game i don't know did you
are you clicked in this there wait i saw
something it's just a controller that
doesn't work
oh
is it synced up
properly let me see look if you don't
take the time to do this right i'm out
of here
fine why not sure you're gonna play
keyboard
i did i'm hoping i get into the game and
it just works okay
classic newtonian newtonian newton was
right about a lot of things yeah newton
he had some good ideas
but do i believe any of them
clearly there was a subdivide in his
theories that there had to be a
non-newtonian yeah i have a feeling that
it's going to be tough enough as it is
screw you isaac okay
oh
that's very pretty
that's nice
that's not certain
[Music]
that's us they should be watching the
that us with us yeah shouldn't they be
cheering yeah i think i know what's
gonna go wrong
oh oh oh
hi
hang on i gotta make sure my recording
is right i don't
i think i remember all my devices
crashing the other day okay sure i'm
gonna guess everything's fine oh
welcome aboard
okay
you got the keyboard
no
oh you're so screwed you can go do you
have a wireless adapter i don't
i don't know no i don't have one wait
let me let me leave and then you see if
it just works by yourself oh
are you in oh it works oh it works oh
okay and newton can get [ __ ] yeah yeah
[ __ ] news
[ __ ] newton and i want to fig newton
right now
those are good every fig nunes yeah we
call them fig rolls over here uh but i
had them when i had kovit and i was
stuck in a hotel room i was like what is
a fig newton how exotic there we go
okay
oh
i'm can i do the wave
hey
okay i'm orange all right
i'm assuming i grabbed things welcome
aboard crew base operation now commands
got it
oh okay
you got lefty down yep we left these
down
we got righty down right he's down
okay grab oh
all right grab
open the hatch grab okay you got it
i'm gonna call you okay i'm gonna call
you big cheese cause you're you're
orange
cheese is having a problem right now
zero g situation is kinda having an
effect on me
all right what if i pull you down by
after something
ah there you go
you can be my gravity all right i'll
i'll hold you down i'll keep you
grounded i'm your grounded buddy yeah
actually now you're just kind of
weighing me down
no no no i'm your gravity no no no this
is our destiny we must okay okay do not
slam my head in the house
you do not we're at this door i'll let
go
all right
yeah there's a fine line there's a
lesson to be learned
oh you could just springboard hold on i
want to springboard off you okay ran on
my head oh i'm having an orientation
issue
pump me in the dome
i go
to the vastness of space the toggle grab
i'm gonna can i change the toggle
grabber is that in your settings
oh i'm not toggle why am i toggle grab
yeah that's that's hard
yeah i'll live with it
wait what would have been the newton
controls i don't know man this feels
like newton but
honestly who knows
how did newton know
newton was a [ __ ] everyone knows this
he's a hack
oh my god the the
god this grab is gonna
this is gonna take me a while okay it's
like two babies learning how to walk yep
okay
just gotta be uh hey
dick move
okay push and pull your body through the
space
okay
[Music]
and
oh my god the dog
this is like an opposite sort of
situation isn't it yeah it is okay okay
i don't know where i go hey oh there's a
bed there
i might want to space man
i'm gonna i'm already angry
dude you're the one who finished getting
over it i i just gave up you never
finished it
no i hell no that was a pain you can go
back
people would want to see that no
i enjoy having my brain in my head all
right fair enough
uh solar cells is the only source of
energy available in space itself
sunlight okay
that's not true there's asteroids that
are probably using some sort of momentum
well when you come up with a momentum
engine that's good enough to power a
space station then we can get some
asteroids look if you can put a hamster
on a wheel and it makes electricity
just put a hamster in space just put a
asteroid in a wheel and let it go i see
here the hamster on it i see yeah i got
you okay
if you configure internal power systems
and reoriented
i'm not done being stupid what if you
put a hamster on an asteroid in space if
it runs is it going to rotate the
asteroid and spin it in space
perpetual motion machine yeah okay i'm
done being stupid now what were we
supposed to do
too late oh i'm apparently grabbing onto
you it's okay take me with you
operations manual oh my god
okay
all right it's the left one
all right so you see this you flick the
willy donker which one
which one's the wheel push the things
you know numbers one two three it's a
sequence
okay the the two looks like valves on a
trumpet i'm gonna play a d-flat
and then plug it in
is that all
plungers down
no i uh wait d flat was a c no yes so
i'll oscillate
and you d flat
uh and then if only we had a third
friend
to do the last goddamn if only
failed from the beginning yeah okay at
this point in my life if i don't have a
third friend i don't think i'm ever
gonna get one so
god i wish i could toggle grab like you
big cheese
you'll never be as good as me
apparently not
hello okay is this the flicky willy
dunker oh no it's students through that
door where you are
i'm good with directions and
orienteering myself
bad with whatever the hell else this
game needs
i'm glad one of us can orient oh my god
[Music]
the doors
the oh
i'll be your push here we go here we go
with my girth i got it
there's no way people in space actually
do this i mean they probably do
i shouldn't have touched it
oh
all right
i'm losing all sense of which arm goes
where
all right i i me i've made it i've
deflated apparently but i did it in the
wrong order i apologize that's okay
that's okay i'll be in there in no time
i just i if only i had something to grab
okay
there we go
oh but why hitting other things no
that's the wrong way you got this man i
thought you had this
i'm just gonna die here
i've decided
no i'm going no i'm going to stupid
[ __ ] monkey friends of mine come here
with wrong hand
i've got you fine okay wait fine wait
wait we're going back hang on squeezing
pushing
birthing
hang on
flinging my legs my legs they can do it
push
push push oh there's nothing there
hold on oh god
why is this so difficult there there you
go push push
there you go
uh
oh my god okay i'm through i'm through
watch
[ __ ] this
oh my god this is the worst oh
god the wrong way help
help
okay oh
yeah
okay how do i orient myself
oh my god
my fingers don't want to cooperate with
this game
okay let me see if there's a part if i
have hey wait let me see if i can get
[ __ ] out of here what is movement style
oh no
oh
did you take over
okay go all right i'm just gonna try
assisted and see
it's just like driving a car now yeah
what is this what is
well this doesn't seem oh
oh my
god my feet are kicking
swim swim through his face
oh my god that's actually how you do it
oh
even unassisted oh
okay wait hang on let me just go back
and we just do the kickies okay that is
much better wait no you're sorry sorry
here you go
you didn't take control of me
no
no this is fine this is fine this is
fine oh
i've never listened to science a day in
my life yeah you're right okay so
okay the power's on
oh yeah
uh where are you going there bud
you need to squeeze fast i'll make
myself small no no those are already
pressed i think we got to reset this
jangle oh you're right you're right
you're right you're right
um
let me just swim through space
yeah
you oh
hi
you
the power's on
i'll get out of your way
okay
oh oh oh oh you got you got it you got
it
yeah it is so backwards because
oh
look at that i couldn't have done it
without you buddy yeah apparently
yeah i'm not used to like
pushing to
pull yeah see
i'm usually the opposite like
in regular gravity this is opposite
okay i'm getting better at it we are
learning
we're our brains are growing oh yeah oh
yeah we're learning
we're totally learning right now come on
oh got it
i would love to see speed runs of this
game oh my god they have to be gods they
clip right outside they go in spaces i
don't seem to be moving
okay okay
we reorient ourselves
it's fine
[Music]
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna oh my god
i'm gonna close this off
what happens when we gotta go back what
if that's the self-destruct to blow that
section of the ship away
let us be done with it
we've entirely given up
so we accomplished nothing
i'm doing anything but smiling hey put
boobs on that calculator
okay hold on hold on what
can i oh
oh newton
oh you are you scientific [ __ ]
he's done it again
[Music]
okay yeah i'm kind of getting it now
yeah yeah it's starting to make sense
all right let me
wrangle this
oh it's not it's not wang you got it you
got there we go there we go there we go
okay
okay one down two down
hey
now we're get what do we do if we get
another objective i don't remember it
yeah it says that we've got the array
now
the top right the uh the array i see
it's over there on the right why is
there blood there you seen that
oh yeah that's a hundred percent blood
that is extremely good that's a good
sign that's a good sign that's okay all
right considering how it takes to
control this it's probably some of ours
orienting
we're in again wait hold on i can't
orient anything
backwards i'm zooming out i'm zooming in
it won't let me
it orients to my head that's what i do
it it it's i want mark's wild rice no no
no no no no it's fine big cheese it's
fine
yeah i need a name for you call me uh
little sperm
a little spur a little sperm and big
cheese we're calling me spunk together
together that's a good sandwich
okay
uh there's some kind of
some kind of a
oh oh grab that thingy and put it in
here
i'm trying maybe
i'm are we like [ __ ] up this space
station no no no no no no this is how
things are supposed to be it's a drawing
of a slide newton was wrong
he had no idea what he was talking about
that idiot you threw it up here i'm
trying to get it out so that i can get
the other thing in here idiot okay name
calling's not going to get us anywhere
all right big sperm little sperm
you call me big sperm i don't have i
don't have many i just have the one
you have to work for that name all right
okay someday
when i grow up i won't be a big sperm
oh boy
is that even a thing you can grab i got
it has to be a a power thing yeah this
stupid clipboard that i got out five
minutes ago wasn't still here
and someone
i just love picturing it from the
outside sure there's no sound in space
but it's just you banging your head
going
oh no no no no no no no
oh don't worry sperm okay how do i get
this in here am i supposed to get this
in here this is just a book this is a
book
[Music]
is this a book yeah
that's that's a that's uh
i mean throw it in there and see oh yeah
it's just that easy oh
don't worry come on your sperm find the
hole i am sperm
but that's why there's millions of me we
have a very poor sense of direction
the immune system
it destroys us
[Music]
the ph
is system
oh god oh please please
i'm just resting my head ugh
better you than me
i think this is just a book i think this
is a fruitless industry i'm
not giving up until you try there's no
way that the developers would be this
cruel this early
yeah they would
oh
well i tried everything
i've tried everything we're all out of
ideas all right let's go sperm hang on i
think i saw something with this uh this
looks like a crowbar there was a crowbar
in the room exactly opposite to us that
seemed to be stuck in something and i
think we got to unstuck it
you got it you got it you got it i got
it you're right there
now i'm just saying you got like the
idea down oh okay all right
which hand is which orienting okay okay
go little rock stare
newton and his [ __ ] phony baloney
[ __ ]
yeah
you could knew my right kick his head
you know don't you hate when newtonians
show up at your door
try to preach you the word of newton
have you heard the good word of gravity
get out of here
i don't believe in that [ __ ]
they like throw an apple in the air
before they knock in the door
and it's like have you heard of gravity
dunk
oh there it is i got it oh good
i'm go to a free ball right now all
right kill me please end it
gladly right in the armpits the human
weak point
you ever watched fist of the north star
read this with the north side what is it
gold
money money
why is it
what's their suitcase
it's bitcoin it's nfts
or i'll
take it
oh so much ethereum
wait is it money is that leaves wait i
think it's leaves it's ridge crisps no
they're gonna cut the instruments
all right i'm gonna
maybe we open that other one next to it
you see that other container over there
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'll throw this i'm gonna throw that
down there because we're probably gonna
need it for something else
unless we needed to open this thing
i can't grab it
yeah what's your arm switch there you go
all right i'll go okay your suitcase got
the other one
oh
that looks handy that's good you can
make anything for duct tape okay
that's tape
i can't reach that other one
okay you got that oh oh there you go oh
god
it's so close
newton saved me you're one of those
newtonians
you probably believe in a gravitational
earth oh yeah sure
your version of karma equal and opposite
reactions oh
newton everyone talks about newton's
third law but what was his first and
second law no talk backing and i'm gonna
hit you
ah yeah yeah we all went to newton's
school when we were kids
was a spanker for sure
he was old school
oh god oh my god oh god
if only ben franklin were here did we
need to do any of this
what did we i
what are we
but made to suffer i think we need the
crowbar to open up that red one with the
blood on it
uh oh good point it's all the way down
here
uh you got it oriented
yeah it's like the whole world gets
shifted upside down and suddenly all my
perspectives get wrong where's the
where's the crowbar i thought it was up
here where that's a book not the book
i don't want to learn where where
where'd the crowbar go wait oh no did it
go down the other shaft the door that i
should have locked
oh god no
oh it did the wrench is down here as
well no
i'm going for it oh i thought i had it i
did not have it
hope
no where the [ __ ] is it this doesn't
make any sense
how do i turn uh-huh
[Music]
there's no way it's all the way back
there's no way
we
where
it's right there that's right above you
big cheese
right there
get it
throw it to me
what a throw
no no no
okay
don't you get away from me now all right
oh the camera
i got it
grab it
oh my god you're memorizing this moment
oh oh no i'm memorializing your failure
oh
not this
anything but this
okay
here we go ow my head
luckily there's no fall damage in space
uh maybe we don't break that door open
maybe we actually fix this [ __ ] we're
assuming that some kind of alien
invasion is happening but maybe maybe
not maybe we're just doing some good
old-fashioned good space fun uh what is
it wait what is this weird oscillating
oscillator thing
yeah i thought that's why you had to put
the thing in the thing and then it was
gonna do a thing what thing
like i
if you put a thing in the hole that gray
gap and then the pink turned blue
oh that's the array that's what we have
to fix it's to the top yeah yeah oh i
see oh i see it we just open up the door
and then we
you know
wait get out of here wrench this is a
crowbar situation did you try throwing
that switch yet
no
[Music]
it's already in place man
can't grab it it's just
oh god i'm so talented
no i [ __ ] it up well that was conv
oh wait it was open what did you do all
right you hold that i'm gonna go through
oh wait no it's open
i'm gonna still gonna go through
i think we need the crowbar to fix no no
no no that's important
no not like this
okay i got i got you go you focus on go
i need some privacy right now
you go you go
you
you i don't know where i'm going you
okay maybe if i
orient oh that was exactly what we
needed
[Laughter]
pictures
there we go
i don't think this works
i think that was just a situation the
most [ __ ] aggravating thing i've done
my legs can't grab my my hand
can let me down newton's legs would grab
i'd be better floating as a corpse than
i would
trying anything here
it's just as soon as i get turned around
i can't do anything oh okay i'm just
gonna go through here so i'm not in the
[ __ ] way body block in this crowbar
no no not like this i don't need to go
now no
lunch
why god oh my
oh
you can do this you can do this i gotta
go get the girl bar now
it's right there it's right there it's
right there it's right there it's right
there climb slime oh so sublime
that's kind of back where we got it oh
my god shut up
oh man
i'm locking you out
yeah you better i'm gonna go space crazy
oh you know what
right there come one
[Music]
there i got it
okay
[Music]
don't please don't throw a chair no no
no no no i that's you don't throw your
mouse that's the old me that's the old
markiplier that people miss i won't be
that person again
see you can't move when the crowbar is
in your way because you can't grab
anything yeah you're right you're right
about that so i gotta throw it right no
that's a fool's task
let go of it no no no no no no no no you
got it no no oh i've never seen a sperm
move so well i know right watch this
okay fling oh he's so talented here we
go
i don't want to grab that wrench i want
to grab anything but that wrench and i'm
through
this
here big cheese take it take it again
pull it in and take
[Applause]
oh
barely made it
okay all right that was close oh wow oh
come here and i'll clip this to your
back what am i going outside why do i
yeah i just gotta clip it to your hip
why do i get why
you want me to clip it to mine why do i
go outside oh hey girl i don't want him
no uh
what are you gonna have to do oh god
is i'm gonna grab this switch
and then you're gonna go outside okay
why didn't we think about how i don't
have a clip so i'll hold on in case i
die why did we
why why did we bring the crowbar out
here where it could fly off into space
and be lost forever i can't hear you
there's a vacuum in space huh
newton was an [ __ ] about a lot of
things but he got the space thing right
all right newton
yeah i think so
you're gonna want to go down there to
the tourney wheelie
little sperm
going out
shockingly doing okay
[Applause]
oh god i don't want to be here i don't
want to be here okay i might cut off
your tether
i shouldn't
all right i have the thing
now you're going to want to do that in a
counterclockwise motion okay what's
counterclockwise
and lefty lucy
[Music]
okay hang on there's literally arrows on
the thing i got it
that array
okay i gotta push ah i have to like
millions of years of evolution
scientific billion dollars just let two
morons out and lose some species
hey hey [ __ ] how do we get on the space
mission again
just sign this cereal box and we'd be
good all right cool i did it
oh that's on earth
yeah that is not earth
are we at enceladus or something inside
when why what
captain what
that's the moon outside saturn it's got
an ocean for a crust actually it's got
eyes
oh
reporter mission control
oh [ __ ] a walkie-talkie okay
wait what's that what's the juice box
over there what juice box go get it
is that an order cap
yes
or uh i'm terrified i don't think you
have any more i don't have any more
lines it's okay come on back in thanks
for watching
big sperm
you did good you got upgraded okay
no you're kicking out into space big
sperm that's okay watch this move oh god
oh god oh we call this one the flagpole
hey look at my pulse i
[Music]
i don't believe i don't believe i don't
believe
if you close your eyes and poke your
ears newton was wrong
okay and
swing swamp
perfect
oh my legs okay it's okay i'm just gonna
lay it oh jesus
i wish my ass wasn't so fat oh god
you got this
okay i oh i can grab the rope
do not okay hang on
wait if i
wait what did press a do
if you press a it would let go of your
tether pence are you in here for me pins
me
oh god oh
that's probably the worst orientation i
could have done that in
yep all right hang on if i just
swing
grab
in like that oh he's surgical it's like
trying to do both hands at the same time
we'll always [ __ ] you
okay
and i'm unclipping my s and i can't i'm
trying to i gotta i gotta there you go
help me captain i'm helpless without you
oh no you're a big sperm now you got it
put an arm down to your right and press
a i'm telling you you're gonna want to
do a grabby i'm telling you oh grab
first
ah
interesting
what the [ __ ] was the point with krober
maybe we didn't maybe it was literally
just jammed in and we needed to get it
out for the jam oh oh
i may have locked you in uh that's okay
i can get out don't worry about it don't
worry captain
there's a switch there on the top of the
tournament i see it bam
he's busy
oh what a legend oh that thing didn't
come out here huh
it came out back at the start wha what
oh yeah mission control wait the
walkie-talkie right i'm gonna bring the
duct tape
okay we're gonna need it
that's a good cord i need it that's a
good call
and i'm relaxing
relaxy
warn a guy before you orient yourself i
mean
oh drifting through i'm putting hands
off the controller on this one uh i've
hit an obstacle that's okay
okay man these fallopian tubes
plugged in the sperm tube huh i pushed
it
let me get that calculator out of the
way for you captain thank you excuse me
i can't read these hieroglyphics man
i can't read it at all
okay all i'm doing you didn't press the
thing
what we're doing is pressing the oh
you can talk to him you're the captain
i'm the captain yeah you got the orange
suit
i wonder we're [ __ ] losing okay you
think it'd be better if i was the
captain
look our captain died it's just like
long ago before we even got here our
captain died look it's not crowbars and
calculators in here man yeah oh god
[Applause]
[Music]
you